Jake:哎呀卧槽
Jake: Oh crap
Alice: 竟然不是一样长的
Alice: They aren't the same length
Alice: 顺眼了
Alice: Looks better
Jake: 喂
Jake: Hello
Jake: 喂喂哎哎到哪了
Jake: Hello, where are you?
Jake: 到哪了
Jake: Where are you?
Jake: 喂喂
Jake: Hello
Jake: 到哪了
Jake: Where are you?
Jake: where are you
Jake: 我靠听不见吗
Jake: Can’t you hear me?
Jake: 喂
Jake: Hello
Jake: 喂啊
Jake: where are you
Jake: 卧槽
Jake: Damn
其他人：哎呀我的妈呀大哥啊
Others: Oh my god, bro
Jake: 唉你好
Jake: Hey, hello
其他人： 是你定的吗
Others: Did you make the reservation?
Jake: 对是
Jake: Yes, I did
其他人：大哥我我3点
Others: Bro, my appointment was at 3
其他人：我10点半到的
Others: I got here at 10:30
其他人：我都等了45分钟了
Others: I've been waiting for 45 minutes
其他人：您这个就就得加加那个什么费了
Others: You'll need to pay an extra fee for this
Jake: 嗯好加加加
Jake: Alright, alright, I'll pay
其他人： 我的妈呀
Others: Oh my god
其他人：我都等我喊这么半天门你们都没听见
Others: I've been shouting at the door for so long, and you didn't hear me
Jake: 我不不道真真真不道啊
Jake: I really didn't know, I really didn't know
其他人：有个码您看一下
Others: There's a code, check it out
Jake: 行行我
Jake: Okay, okay, I will
其他人： 我这喊我都喊了好久了都
Others: I've been shouting for a long time
Jake: 这个这个电话
Jake: This phone
Jake: 电话留错了
Jake: The phone number is wrong
Jake: 我这个是什么
Jake: What is this?
其他人：你先看看是不是这个码
Others: Check if this is the right code
Jake: 我我怎么看
Jake: How do I check this?
Jake: 淘宝是吧
Jake: Is this from Taobao?
其他人：啊你短信里面有个短信
Others: Yeah, there's a message in your SMS
Jake: 我短信短信啊
Jake: My SMS, alright
其他人：你电话留错了
Others: You wrote the wrong phone number
Jake: 我电话留错了
Jake: I wrote the wrong phone number
其他人：留错了那你就没有了嗯
Others: If it's wrong, you won't get it, uh-huh
其他人：你看一下收件码吗
Others: Check the receipt code
其他人：啊他联系了他了吗
Others: Did he contact you?
其他人：他出来取了
Others: Did he come out to get it?
其他人：他给你钱了吗
Others: Did he give you money?
其他人：没呢等会你先给我车间码再给他
Others: Not yet, wait, give me the workshop code first, then give it to him
其他人：一会给我钱
Others: He'll give me the money later
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
其他人：没事你先给我码吧
Others: It's fine, just give me the code first
其他人：大哥我得赶紧走了呀
Others: Bro, I need to leave quickly
其他人：一会超时了都
Others: It'll be overtime soon
其他人：都超时了
Others: It's already overtime
其他人：等等我看一下
Others: Wait, let me check
其他人：收件码对对
Others: Check the collection code.
其他人： 他没有收件码吗
Others: Doesn't he have a collection code?
其他人：他你电话留错
Others: He left the wrong phone number.
其他人： 他电话留错了
其他人： 没有码
Others: No code.
其他人：111511 三个1一个5是吧
Others: 111511, three 1's and a 5, right?
其他人：啊他电话留错了还
Others: Ah, he left the wrong number again.
其他人： 啊对啊行好嘞
Others: Ah, yeah, okay.
Jake: 我刚刚跟他讲了电话留错了
Jake: I just told him he left the wrong number.
Jake: 他可能
Jake: He might...
其他人：他也给你打
Others: He also called you.
其他人： 我也给你打
Others: I also called you.
其他人： 我敲半天了行吧
Others: I've been knocking for ages, okay?
其他人：呃你扫微信啊
Others: Uh, you can scan WeChat.
Jake: 微信吗微信
Jake: WeChat? WeChat?
其他人：哎呀我扫
Others: Oh, I'll scan it.
其他人：给我这个嗓子给我干干了
Others: My throat is all dry from this.
Jake: 不好意思不好意思
Jake: Sorry, sorry.
Jake: 给你扫你扫
Jake: You scan it, you scan it.
Jake: 扫扫扫
Jake: Scan, scan, scan.
其他人：要几分几分
Others: How many minutes?
其他人：几分钟的话就不那什么了哦
Others: If it's a few minutes, then it's fine.
其他人：结果等了就4450分钟
Others: In the end, I waited for like 4450 minutes.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 不好意思
Jake: Sorry.
Jake: 这个一般怎么搞
Jake: How do you usually handle this?
其他人：就一分钟
Others: Just one minute.
其他人： 一分钟一块钱就得了
Others: One minute, one dollar, that's it.
Jake: 哦那现在多少分钟
Jake: Oh, so how many minutes now?
Jake: 呃404545 不好意思哦
Jake: Uh, 404545, sorry.
其他人：没事没事
Others: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 好慢走啊
Jake: Alright, take care.
其他人：万一你们家门铃也坏了吧
Others: What if your doorbell is broken too?
Jake: 这个我不知道
Jake: I don't know about that.
Jake: 这个都是租的
Jake: This place is rented.
Jake: 好好好谢谢你
Jake: Okay, okay, thank you.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 谢谢您啊好
Jake: Thank you so much, alright.
其他人：啊没事没事
Others: Ah, it's nothing, it's nothing.
Katrina:  那只能在这跳
Katrina: We can only dance here.
Katrina:  那天就可以在这跳
Katrina: That day we can dance here.
Katrina:  然后他们坐这坐坐这
Katrina: And then they'll sit here, sit here.
Lucia: 队形变化
Lucia: Formation change.
Lucia: 上面就大家就一直站着不要变队形了
Lucia: Up there, everyone should just stand and not change formation.
Jake: 这是舞台
Jake: This is the stage.
Katrina:  这不用编队形啊
Katrina: No need to arrange formation here.
Katrina:  就在这啊
Katrina: Just here.
Jake: 这是舞台
Jake: This is the stage.
Jake: 是吧在这围观
Jake: Right, we can watch from here.
Katrina:  这是舞台
Katrina: This is the stage.
Katrina:  因为二楼太小了嘛
Katrina: Because the second floor is too small.
Katrina:  那肯定晚上跳舞在外面跳
Katrina: We definitely have to dance outside at night.
Katrina:  这10哎刚好就在这
Katrina: This spot is just perfect.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 但我感觉这里这也只能站平着站
Lucia: But I feel like we can only stand side by side here.
Katrina:  哎只有5个人撒开
Katrina: Yeah, only 5 people can spread out.
Lucia: 我们没法前后站人
Lucia: We can't stand people front and back.
Lucia: 对吧我感觉
Lucia: Right, that's what I feel.
Katrina:  2个差不多最
Katrina: 2 people at most.
Jake: 下面也站几个
Jake: Stand a few below too.
Katrina:  多站两排吧
Katrina: Maybe two rows.
Jake: 下面站几个会摔着吗
Jake: If we have people below, will they fall?
Katrina:  可以前三后二这种
Katrina: We can do three in the front, two in the back.
Lucia: 下面下面不能站
Lucia: Below, we can't stand people below.
Jake: 不能站人
Jake: No people below.
Lucia: 对下面不好跳
Lucia: Right, it's hard to dance below.
Katrina:  前三后二那种
Katrina: Three in front, two in back.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 好喝哈
Tasha: Delicious, huh?
Katrina:  还行动作幅度小
Katrina: And the movements are smaller.
Lucia: 对就是可以
Lucia: Yeah, that's possible.
Lucia: 不用就是整个
Lucia: No need for the whole...
Lucia: 就是怎么形容的
Lucia: How to describe it?
Lucia: 就是他这个队列间间距不用很大
Lucia: The spacing between the formation doesn't need to be large.
Lucia: 就是可能前三个人稍微往前点
Lucia: Maybe the three in front can move slightly forward.
Lucia: 后两个人稍微往后一点点
Lucia: The two in the back can move slightly backward.
Lucia: 一点1.5排的那种那种间距就可以了
Lucia: A spacing of about 1.5 rows should be fine.
Katrina:  哦这可以晒衣服
Katrina: Oh, this can dry clothes.
Jake: 挺好这边再搞一个舞台幕布
Jake: Great, let's set up a stage curtain here.
Lucia: 啊可以把投影搬到外面来吗
Lucia: Ah, can we move the projector outside?
Jake: 不是就是一个幕
Jake: No, it's just a screen.
Jake: 嗯布就是真实的physical的一个布
Jake: Yeah, it's an actual physical screen.
Katrina:  那你得买一个这种
Katrina: Then you need to buy one like this.
Jake: 在这一挂
Jake: Hang it here.
Jake: 对这布以前买过挺多
Jake: Yes, we bought quite a few of these before.
Jake: 20多块钱一个
Jake: They were around 20 bucks each.
Jake: 这么拿的
Jake: You hold it like this.
Lucia: 像影像那个影棚的那种吗
Lucia: Like the ones in a film studio?
Katrina:  量一下午
Katrina: Measure for an afternoon.
Katrina:  网上找吗
Katrina: Search online?
Jake: 对就是广告打广告
Jake: Yeah, it's for advertising.
Jake: 那个村门口的那种大广告你知道吗
Jake: You know those big ads at the entrance of the village?
Lucia: 哦哈哈哈哈可以
Lucia: Oh, hahaha, that's fine.
Jake: 哦哈哈哈可以
Jake: Oh, haha, that's fine.
Lucia: 我们可以想想
Lucia: We can think about it.
Katrina:  吃吧吃吧
Katrina: Let's eat, let's eat.
Lucia: 上面要什么花纹或者颜色的
Lucia: What kind of pattern or color do you want on it?
Jake: 这什么曲子呀
Jake: What song is this?
Katrina:  奔跑的青春
Katrina: Running Youth.
Katrina:  哈哈但是还没决定好几个
Katrina: Haha, but we haven't decided on a few yet.
Katrina:  要看一下大家难度
Katrina: We need to see how difficult it is for everyone.
Katrina:  打那个有点慢
Katrina: It's a bit slow.
Katrina:  拿筷子了吗
Katrina: Did you get the chopsticks?
Jake: 我又被diss了
Jake: I got dissed again.
Jake: 你又diss我哈哈
Jake: You dissed me again, haha.
Jake: 总不回他的消息
Jake: I never reply to his messages.
Jake: 他让我吃早饭
Jake: He told me to eat breakfast.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Tasha: 看你哦别看了
Tasha: Look at you, stop looking.
Tasha: 哈哈哈这锅烧导热性太好
Tasha: Hahaha, this pot has great heat conduction.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 哦导多了
Jake: Oh, that's too much.
Lucia: 我觉得这一看就很好吃
Lucia: I think it looks delicious.
Jake: 是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 不不会
Tasha: No, it won't.
Jake: 为啥不会就会
Jake: Why not? It will.
Lucia: 这个牛奶是你的了
Lucia: This milk is yours.
Tasha: 我没有信心
Tasha: I don't have confidence.
Jake: 试试试试
Jake: Try it, try it.
Lucia: 我如果需要加咖啡请自行加
Lucia: If you need more coffee, please add it yourself.
Lucia: 因为我不知道你要喝多浓
Lucia: Because I don't know how strong you want it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 好没关系
Jake: No problem.
Tasha: 加糖
Tasha: Add sugar.
Jake: 糖在哪
Jake: Where's the sugar?
Alice: 我拿一下吧
Alice: I'll get it.
Tasha: 糖糖糖蘸糖
Tasha: Sugar, sugar, dip the sugar.
Lucia: 这个碗
Lucia: This bowl.
Lucia: 倒一个再拿一个好了
Lucia: Pour one and then get another one.
Alice: 我我不要
Alice: No, I don't want it.
Alice: 我的已经结束了
Alice: I'm done with mine.
Lucia: 啊啊
Lucia: Ah, ah.
Alice: 我碗都刷完了
Alice: I've already washed my bowl.
Lucia: 那我就先拿走一个这个
Lucia: Then I'll take this one away first.
Alice: 拿个纸擦一下
Alice: Wipe it with a tissue.
Alice: 放放这个放糖吧
Alice: Put the sugar in this one.
Jake: 要什么纸
Jake: What tissue?
Alice: 这这里面不是放糖蘸的吗
Alice: Isn't this for dipping sugar?
Alice: 还是自己倒自己碗里
Alice: Or just pour it into your own bowl.
Tasha: 这是自己的碗
Tasha: This is your own bowl.
Katrina: 自己倒自己碗里
Katrina: Pour it into your own bowl.
Alice: 谁的碗
Alice: Whose bowl is it?
Katrina:  没人用就给他吧
Katrina: If no one's using it, just give it to him.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:你自己倒吧
Alice: Pour it yourself.
Alice: 我不知道你要多少
Alice: I don't know how much you want.
Alice: 你说停吧
Alice: Just tell me when to stop.
Jake: 我我我来倒就好
Jake: I'll pour it myself, it's fine.
Jake: 为什么倒不下来
Jake: Why won't it pour?
Alice: 因为他有点受潮了
Alice: Because it's a bit damp.
Tasha: 这是绵白糖本来就这么绵
Tasha: This powdered sugar is naturally like this.
Jake: 哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake: 买的好挺好
Jake: Good buy, pretty nice.
Alice: 哦天哪跟谁
Alice: Oh my God, with whom?
Jake: 我去
Jake: Oh man.
Alice: 分点吧哈哈哈
Alice: Share some, haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 强行售卖
Jake: Forced sale.
Tasha: 哎哈哈
Tasha: Oh haha
Alice: 你不得你给他弄碎点
Alice: You can't, you need to crush it a bit
Jake: 强行售卖
Jake: Forced selling
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Is that okay?
Lucia: 这个里面就应该有糖的吗
Lucia: Should there be sugar in this?
Jake: 还要吗
Jake: Do you want more?
Jake: 分点
Jake: Share a bit
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice: 江苏人的
Alice: From Jiangsu people
Jake: 分分你一点
Jake: I'll share some with you
Lucia:  呃也可以
Lucia: Uh, okay
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright
Lucia: 你这个倒太多了
Lucia: You poured too much
Tasha: 对他骚太多了哈哈
Tasha: Yeah, it's too much, haha
Jake: 对都都都是
Jake: Yeah, it's all too much
Jake: 是我放太多了
Jake: I put too much
Alice: 你要糖吗轩
Alice: Do you want sugar, Xuan?
Tasha: 然后嗯贴面站
Tasha: And then, hmm, face-to-face stand
Jake: 要吗好
Jake: Do you want it? Okay
Katrina:  我不要糖
Katrina: I don't want sugar
Jake: 你也不要
Jake: You don't want it either
Alice: 我不吃糖
Alice: I don't eat sugar
Alice: 我会流鼻血
Alice: I'll get a nosebleed
Jake: 啊确实
Jake: Oh, definitely
Katrina:  这舞也行
Katrina: This dance is okay too
Tasha: 你要接受
Tasha: You need to accept it
Lucia: 这个好像是我们那校庆
Lucia: This seems like our school anniversary
Katrina:  我高中跳过
Katrina: I danced it in high school
Katrina:  高中晚会跳过
Katrina: Danced it at the high school evening party
Lucia:  虽然我觉得动作可能不完全一样
Lucia: Although I think the moves might be different
Lucia:  但就这个背景音乐
Lucia: But the background music is the same
Katrina:  this其实还行
Katrina: This is actually okay
Katrina:  如果你能接受奔跑的青春的话
Katrina: If you can accept the youth run
Katrina:  那你更加能接受这个
Katrina: Then you can accept this even more
Katrina:  慢一点动作更简单
Katrina: Slower and simpler moves
Katrina:  噜噜响
Katrina: Louder sound
Lucia: 就这个也可以
Lucia: This one is fine too
Lucia:  这个鼓点也比较清晰
Lucia: The drum beats are clearer
Lucia: 就我喜欢这种
Lucia: I like this kind
Lucia: 我能很快找到他的节奏的
Lucia: I can quickly find its rhythm
Alice: 充电宝在哪
Alice: Where's the power bank?
Alice: 我这个可能快快要充电了
Alice: I think mine needs to be charged soon.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 别把我的充电宝拔走了让我去拿
Tasha: Don't take my power bank, let me go get it.
Alice: 你告诉我在哪我去拿就行了
Alice: Just tell me where it is and I'll get it.
Jake: 我我来拿我来拿
Jake: I'll get it, I'll get it.
Alice: 味道怎么样
Alice: How does it taste?
Tasha: 我觉得用错面团了啊面粉了
Tasha: I think we used the wrong dough, or flour.
Jake: 密度刚好
Jake: The density is just right.
Jake: 这这个面的密度刚好
Jake: The density of this dough is just right.
Jake: 这是你的吗
Jake: Is this yours?
Jake: 这是这是这是
Jake: This, this, this...
Jake: 这是啥呀
Jake: What is this?
Alice:这个不知道谁的
Alice: I don't know whose it is.
Alice: 这不是他的
Alice: It's not his.
Alice: 他的是个小蝴蝶
Alice: His has a little butterfly on it.
Jake: 这啥啊
Jake: What is this?
Alice: 不对小翅膀
Alice: No, little wings.
Jake: 怎么看呢
Jake: How do you look at it?
Lucia: 是我的吗
Lucia: Is it mine?
Jake: 是露西亚
Jake: It's Lucia's.
Alice: 啊姜
Alice: Ah, ginger.
Jake: 这这是姜
Jake: This is ginger.
Jake: 哦是吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia: 嗯是
Lucia: Yeah, it is.
Jake: 这是姜
Jake: This is ginger.
Jake: 哦哦哦哦哦哦好好
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, okay, okay.
Jake: 那你要点
Jake: Do you want some?
Jake: 你也要点
Jake: You also want some?
Jake: 就先放这些
Jake: Just put these first.
Katrina:  我就跳那个
Katrina: I'll just dance to that.
Katrina:  不如跳这个
Katrina: How about dancing to this?
Alice: 味道还行吗
Alice: Does it taste okay?
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Ahahaha.
Katrina:  这还能3分钟呢
Katrina: This still has 3 minutes left.
Tasha: 就是对动作的
Tasha: It's about the moves.
Katrina:  这这动作都重复了
Katrina: The moves are all repetitive.
Jake: 行这个比较明显
Jake: Okay, this one's more obvious.
Jake: 正好你坐着
Jake: Just right, you're sitting.
Katrina:  哦我要充电是吗
Katrina: Oh, I need to charge, right?
Jake: 可以充一会
Jake: We can charge it for a while.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 是不不够啊
Jake: Isn't it enough?
Katrina:  有一种机器人被连上电的感觉
Katrina: It feels like a robot getting powered up.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 连上之后记忆加速
Jake: Once it's connected, memory speeds up.
Jake: 1秒学舞
Jake: Learn a dance in one second.
Katrina:  激活激活了正好
Katrina: Activated, just in time.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 这是谁的
Jake: Whose is this?
Tasha: 这个特别好吃
Tasha: This is really delicious.
Jake: 哈哈哈我
Jake: Hahaha mine.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 我的是吧
Jake: It's mine, right?
Jake: 真的吗
Jake: Really?
Tasha: 真的这是第
Tasha: Yes, this is the first result.
Tasha: 一个成果
Tasha: The first achievement.
Jake: 真的哦真吃了
Jake: Really, you really ate it?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 假吃了还能
Lucia: Fake eating, can still...
Tasha: 别吃了吧哈哈
Tasha: Better not eat it, haha.
Jake: 刚刚那个猪猪侠是怎么跳的
Jake: How did that Pig Hero dance just now?
Jake: 我很好奇
Jake: I'm really curious.
Katrina:  为啥特别简单
Katrina: Why, it's very simple.
Katrina:  就1234才做一个动作
Katrina: Just 1, 2, 3, 4 and then a move.
Lucia: 对这个比较简单哦
Lucia: Yeah, this one's quite simple.
Jake: 好好哎这个看一下
Jake: Okay, let's take a look.
Lucia: 她的节奏节奏感没有那么
Lucia: Her rhythm sense isn't that...
Tasha: 很简单吧
Tasha: It's very simple, right?
Jake: 嗯确实有点呆
Jake: Yeah, it's a bit dull.
Lucia: 那我们可以像雨轩说的
Lucia: Then we can do as Yuxuan said.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 然后跳这个
Lucia: And then dance this.
Jake: 可以都可以
Jake: Sure, we can do that.
Katrina:  人人都可以
Katrina: Everyone can do it.
Katrina:  一人带个蘑菇头像那个蘑菇蘑菇
Katrina: Everyone wears a mushroom head, that mushroom, mushroom.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 啊哈哈
Lucia: Ahaha.
Lucia: 很有道理
Lucia: Makes sense.
Katrina:  嗯买两个头套就行
Katrina: Yeah, just buy two head covers.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 买个那那种气球
Jake: Let's buy one of those balloons.
Jake: 风吹起来
Jake: That blows up with air.
Katrina:  造型的气球吗
Katrina: You mean the shaped balloons?
Katrina:  哦哦哦那个风吹那个人那个的
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh, the one that inflates with air.
Lucia: 嗯是外卖到了吗
Lucia: Hmm, is the delivery here?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 不是外卖美团买药
Lucia: It's not food delivery, it's medicine from Meituan.
Tasha: 点外卖了哦
Tasha: Did you order food delivery?
Jake: 来了
Jake: It's here.
Jake: 嗯嗯好
Jake: Yeah, yeah, okay.
Tasha: 嗯我以为午饭到了
Tasha: Hmm, I thought it was lunch.
Lucia: 喂你好
Lucia: Hello, hi.
Jake: 嗯嗯哼哼哼
Jake: Yeah, yeah, uh-huh, uh-huh.
Lucia:  呃我们是黄色铁门吗
Lucia: Uh, do we have a yellow iron gate?
Tasha: 他是在这
Tasha: He's here.
Katrina:  现在在这
Katrina: He's here now.
Katrina:  我听到他声音了
Katrina: I heard his voice.
Katrina:  他就在这
Katrina: He's right here.
Lucia: 哦这样子
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Lucia: 呃应该是同一个
Lucia: Uh, it should be the same one.
Lucia: 您稍等一下
Lucia: Please hold on a second.
Katrina:  是蓝绿色的
Katrina: It's blue-green.
Lucia: 是一个蓝绿色的建筑
Lucia: It's a blue-green building.
Jake: 嚯
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 这也不是铁门
Jake: This isn't an iron gate.
其他人：我说习惯铁门
Others: I said I was used to iron gates.
Jake: 哈哈哈谢谢谢谢拜拜
Jake: Haha, thank you, thank you, goodbye.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 这隔音这么不好吗
Jake: Is the soundproofing really that bad?
Jake: 我我怎么没听见
Jake: How come I didn't hear it?
Jake: 你耳朵怎么这么好
Jake: How come your hearing is so good?
Jake: 还是隔音太差了
Jake: Or is the soundproofing too bad?
Katrina:  哈哈哈我刚以为你房间有人说话
Katrina: Haha, I thought someone was talking in your room.
Jake: 哦是这样
Jake: Oh, I see.
Jake: 怎么去郑州
Jake: How do you get to Zhengzhou?
Tasha: 哎你怎么是吧
Tasha: Hey, how do you... right?
Jake: 你刚刚打电话说的
Jake: You just mentioned it on the phone.
Jake: 去干嘛呀
Jake: Where are you going?
Alice: 跟我约会
Alice: On a date with me.
Jake: 哦可以
Jake: Oh, sure.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  你要去郑州吗
Katrina: Are you going to Zhengzhou?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  你去郑州干啥开会吗
Katrina: Why are you going to Zhengzhou? For a meeting?
Tasha: 去玩五一
Jake: 五一去郑州
Jake: Going to Zhengzhou for May Day?
Jake: 可以人会很多吧
Jake: There will be a lot of people, right?
Alice: 啊你去郑州
Alice: Ah, you're going to Zhengzhou?
Alice: 不是你郑州去哪啊
Alice: No, where exactly in Zhengzhou are you going?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Katrina:  哈哈哈我有个舍友也是郑州
Katrina: Hahaha, I have a roommate from Zhengzhou.
Alice: 你去
Alice: You should go.
Lucia: 本地人
Lucia: A local.
Alice: 你问我吧问我吧
Alice: You should ask me, ask me.
Tasha: 哦问我吧
Tasha: Oh, ask me.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 我不知道去哪呢还
Tasha: I still don't know where to go.
Tasha: 他们安排我
Tasha: They'll arrange it for me.
Tasha: 我可是个屁人
Tasha: I'm just a nobody.
Alice: 我的天啊
Alice: Oh my god.
Tasha: 我我跟着走
Tasha: I'll just follow along.
Alice: 我觉得去哪玩我都理解不了
Alice: I can't understand where to go for fun.
Katrina:  完了
Katrina: It's over.
Lucia: 哈哈哈嘉怡
Lucia: Hahaha, Jiayi.
Lucia: 我只有碰到比我更屁的朋友的时候
Lucia: Only when I meet friends who are even more clueless than me...
Alice: 带你去洛阳
Alice: Take you to Luoyang.
Lucia: 我才会做计划
Lucia: ...do I make plans.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈你去洛阳跟开封都挺近的
Alice: Hahaha, Luoyang and Kaifeng are both pretty close.
Alice: 从郑州东站出发哈哈哈
Alice: Depart from Zhengzhou East Station, hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈什么
Tasha: Hahaha, what?
Katrina:  哈哈哈郑州最好玩的就是郑州东站
Katrina: Hahaha, the best thing in Zhengzhou is the East Station.
Tasha: 我不是去
Tasha: I'm not going.
Alice: 郑州东站哈哈
Alice: Zhengzhou East Station, haha.
Katrina:  买一张票去别的地方
Katrina: Buy a ticket to somewhere else.
Tasha: 啊好
Tasha: Ah, okay.
Jake: 好啊
Jake: Alright.
Alice: 我跟你说一家
Alice: Let me tell you about a place.
Alice: 超级好吃的那种甜水铺
Alice: It's a super delicious dessert shop.
Tasha: 啊你说吧
Tasha: Oh, go ahead.
Jake: 好你说吧
Jake: Alright, go ahead.
Tasha: 我让万一我不去他们能吃
Tasha: Just in case I don't go, they can still eat.
Alice: 我觉得那一栋楼只有
Alice: I think there are only a few places in that building...
Alice: 就是为数不多的几家活着
Alice: ...that are still alive and kicking.
Tasha: 你说
Tasha: Go on.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Jake: 这个咖啡我是怎么搞啊
Jake: How do I make this coffee?
Alice: 直接啊浓缩液倒进去往上拔
Alice: Just pour the concentrate in and pull up.
Katrina:  就一条拔出来
Katrina: Just pull out one strip.
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, got it.
Alice: 就是大上海城
Alice: It's at Shanghai City.
Jake: 有点多哎
Jake: There's quite a lot.
Tasha: 啊上海城然后呢
Tasha: Oh, Shanghai City, and then?
Katrina:  倒进来就这么
Katrina: Just pour it in like this.
Alice: 东东鲜芋圆
Alice: Dong Dong Fresh Taro Balls.
Katrina:  它非常浓郁
Katrina: It's very rich.
Alice: 东西南北的东
Alice: Dong as in east.
Tasha: 东东鲜芋圆好了
Tasha: Dong Dong Fresh Taro Balls, got it.
Alice: 嗯东东鲜芋圆就他们家巨好吃
Alice: Yeah, Dong Dong Fresh Taro Balls, their stuff is super tasty.
Alice: 你会发现
Alice: You'll find...
Alice: 那个商城基本上是倒闭的状态
Alice: ...that the mall is basically in a state of bankruptcy.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice: 哎
Alice: Hey.
Alice: 你五一要真的去的话你可以来我家玩
Alice: If you really come during May Day, you can come hang out at my place.
Alice: 真的你要不住我家吧
Alice: Seriously, why don't you stay at my place?
Katrina:  节省了一笔房费
Katrina: That'll save on hotel costs.
Alice: 真的你要不住我家吧
Alice: Seriously, why don't you stay at my place?
Alice: 我家也没啥人
Alice: There aren't many people at my place.
Jake: 你你还能带几个人
Jake: Can you bring a few people?
Jake: 哈哈哈住几个人
Jake: Hahaha, how many can stay?
Tasha: 能住几个哈哈
Tasha: How many can stay? Haha.
Alice: 啊哈啊你有几对
Alice: Uh-huh, how many do you have?
Lucia: 对我这离你家很近
Lucia: Right, my place is really close to yours.
Alice: 我家离你家很近
Alice: My place is really close to yours.
Alice: 我也可以去网吧
Alice: I can also go to the internet cafe.
Lucia: 我也可以住两个人吧
Lucia: I can also host two people.
Tasha: 我天呐哈哈
Tasha: Oh my gosh, haha
Alice: 来吧来吧
Alice: Come on, come on
Alice: 你你们有几个人
Alice: How many of you are there?
Lucia: 一只手
Lucia: One hand
Tasha: 应该是3个到4个
Tasha: It should be 3 to 4
Tasha: 呃 4个到5个吧
Tasha: Uh, 4 to 5 maybe
Alice: 啊 把我弟赶出家门
Alice: 赶出家门
Alice: Kick them out of the house
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈嗯
Tasha: Ah, hahahahahahahahaha
Alice: 让他让他不许回来
Alice: Don't let them come back
Katrina:  让他不许回来
Katrina: Don't let them come back
Alice: 然后就可以腾出来房间住了
Alice: Then we can have the room available
Tasha: 4月18号8点开始抢票
Tasha: Tickets go on sale at 8 AM on April 18th
Tasha: 怎么什么都要抢
Tasha: Why does everything need a rush?
Jake: 五一要抢票是吧
Jake: Need to rush for May Day tickets, right?
Jake: 完了五一那会儿我回新加坡
Jake: Oh no, I'm going back to Singapore for May Day
Jake: 是不是特别贵
Jake: Aren't they super expensive?
Jake: 呵呵呵我没订票
Jake: Haha, I haven't booked the tickets yet
Katrina:  还没订票
Katrina: Haven't booked the tickets yet
Jake: 屁人不会订票
Jake: Nobody knows how to book tickets
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 你可以讲你之前的那个故事
Lucia: You can tell your story from before
Alice: 我五一要回家了
Alice: I'm going home for May Day
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice: 我现在还没开始定
Alice: I haven't started booking yet
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈连我一个屁都觉得震惊
Lucia: Haha, even my fart is shocking
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake: 呵呵我上了飞
Jake: Haha, I already boarded the flight
Jake: 先去飞机场再买票
Jake: Buy the ticket at the airport
Katrina:  嗯我是受不了
Katrina: Hmm, I can't handle it
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice: 啊什么
Alice: Ah, what?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because
Tasha: 先去飞机场再买票
Tasha: Buy the ticket at the airport
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah
Jake: 因为这比较省钱
Jake: Because it's cheaper
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 因为如果我提前买票通常赶不上飞机
Jake: Because if I buy tickets in advance, I usually miss the flight.
Jake: 所以就要改签
Jake: So I have to reschedule.
Alice: 原来是这样
Alice: Oh, I see.
Alice: 我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Katrina:  但是你到那买不是很贵吗
Katrina: But isn't it really expensive to buy tickets on the spot?
Katrina:  有的时候
Katrina: Sometimes.
Jake: 但是我每次都赶不上飞机
Jake: But I always miss the flight anyway.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 是原来是这样
Alice: So that's how it is.
Katrina:  受不了你了真的
Katrina: I can't stand you, really.
Jake: 对所以比较省钱
Jake: Yeah, so it saves money.
Alice: 这是能说的吗
Alice: Is that something you can say?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 给外国人一点震撼哈
Alice: Give the foreigners a shock.
Katrina:  嘿嘿嘿
Katrina: Hehehe.
Jake: 这个可以说吧
Jake: It's okay to say this, right?
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 以前试了很多次教训
Jake: I have tried many times before.
Jake: 就是每次都可能提前40分钟check in
Jake: Every time, I might check in 40 minutes early.
Jake: 然后我可能就3938分钟到
Jake: And then I might arrive at 39 or 38 minutes.
Jake: 然后呵呵呵
Jake: And then, haha.
Jake: 就很失望
Jake: It's really disappointing.
Jake: 以后就不买票了
Jake: So I stopped buying tickets in advance.
Alice: 呵我第一次听说
Alice: Haha, this is the first time I've heard that.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 是不是很让人震惊
Lucia: Isn't it shocking?
Alice: 我觉得我已经很很那啥了
Alice: I thought I was already quite something.
Jake: 哎路亚你这个关了
Jake: Hey, Lucia, you turned this off.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Jake: 是哎为什么会关
Jake: Yes, why did it turn off?
Alice: 嗯充电
Alice: Uh, charging.
Jake: 看一下看一下
Jake: Take a look, take a look.
Jake: 什么什么
Jake: What, what?
Tasha: 说不出话来
Tasha: Speechless.
Jake: 哈哈哈太多了
Jake: Hahaha, too much.
Tasha: 还是还是钱太多了
Tasha: Still, still too much money.
Lucia: 他被你吓着了
Lucia: He got scared by you.
Jake: 不是没有
Jake: No, he didn't.
Jake: 还是要省钱
Jake: Still need to save money.
Tasha: 还是钱太多了家里
Tasha: Still too much money at home.
Jake: 还是不能白花钱
Jake: Still can't waste money.
Jake: 就是可以贵一点
Jake: It's okay to be a bit expensive.
Jake: 但是不能白花钱
Jake: But can't waste money.
Tasha: 还是家里钱太多了
Tasha: You must have too much money at home.
Katrina:  笑死我了
Katrina: That's so funny.
Lucia: 他又变白了
Lucia: He's getting paler.
Lucia: 但是我没有关
Lucia: But I didn't close it.
Lucia:  我的嗯嗯哦
Lucia: Oh my...
Tasha: 啊哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha!
Lucia:  关闭了吗
Lucia: Did it close?
Tasha: 接完接电话是不是会自动关
Tasha: Does it automatically close after you finish the call?
Lucia: 会影响
Lucia: It affects it.
Jake: 应该不会
Jake: It shouldn't.
Lucia:  哎他好像真的刚才那圈突然掉线了
Lucia: Hey, it seems like he suddenly disconnected just now.
Lucia: 那我再来一个
Lucia: Let me try again.
Alice: 喂喂你们那个规划我真的很好奇
Alice: Hey, hey, I'm really curious about your plan.
Tasha: 啊我真的很好奇
Tasha: Ah, I'm really curious too.
Alice: 我也想知道郑州有啥玩的
Alice: I also want to know what fun stuff is there in Zhengzhou.
Tasha: 我也想知道
Tasha: I want to know too.
Tasha: 不知道呀玩啥呀
Tasha: No idea, what is there to do?
Katrina:  看下外地人做的攻略你就知道
Katrina: Check out the guides made by non-locals and you'll know.
Alice: 对对对哈哈哈
Alice: Exactly, hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Tasha: 我什么都不知道
Tasha: I don't know anything.
Tasha: 就今天打电话说去郑州玩嘛
Tasha: Just got a call today saying to go play in Zhengzhou.
Tasha: 哈哈我说有空我就去
Tasha: Haha, I said if I'm free, I'll go.
Alice: 是不是你们要去演唱会之类的
Alice: Are you going to a concert or something?
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Alice: 是吗我不知道啊
Alice: Really? I don't know.
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Katrina:  你怎么不来武汉玩
Katrina: Why don't you come to Wuhan to play?
Tasha: 武汉
Tasha: Wuhan?
Tasha: 有人邀请我去哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Someone invited me to go, hahaha.
Katrina:  觉得武汉还是我邀请你
Katrina: Do you think it's me inviting you?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahahaha.
Katrina:  武汉比郑州好玩一点点
Katrina: Wuhan is slightly more fun than Zhengzhou.
Lucia: 我还没去过郑州
Lucia: I haven't been to Zhengzhou yet.
Tasha: 我也没有去过
Tasha: Me neither.
Katrina:  武汉但是武汉五一人应该很多
Katrina: Wuhan, but during May Day, there should be a lot of people.
Alice: 来吧来找我吧
Alice: Come on, come find me.
Tasha: 哈哈五一应该在家
Tasha: Haha, I should be at home during May Day.
Alice: 我五一应该在家
Alice: I should be at home during May Day.
Alice: 我也没开始订票
Alice: I haven't started booking tickets yet.
Alice: 我一看那个票售罄了
Alice: I saw the tickets were sold out.
Alice: 然后我还没开始订
Alice: So I haven't started booking yet.
Lucia:  行那果然是全员批人
Lucia: Well, it turns out everyone is procrastinating.
Alice: 无所谓反正
Alice: It doesn't matter anyway.
Alice: 嗯买不到票就只能
Alice: Hmm, if I can't buy a ticket, then I just can't.
Tasha: 买不到票
Tasha: Can't buy a ticket.
Lucia: 我也经常会提前两三天才订
Lucia: I also often book just two or three days in advance.
Lucia: 但是嗯您知道吗哈哈哈
Lucia: But, you know, hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Jake: 一般大概也就提前两个小时对
Jake: Usually, about two hours in advance, right?
Jake: 就提前两个小时就能有飞机
Jake: Just two hours in advance and you can get a flight.
Alice: 第一次听说
Alice: First time hearing this.
Alice: 真的闻所未闻
Alice: Really unheard of.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 到了机场一看那个板我觉得这个不错
Jake: When I get to the airport and see the board, I think this one is good.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 看看多少钱
Jake: Let's see how much it costs.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 大开眼界
Lucia: Eye-opening.
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha.
Tasha: 闻所未闻
Tasha: Unheard of.
Alice: 我觉得
Alice: I think...
Alice: 我提前一两天买票已经挺极限了
Alice: Booking a ticket one or two days in advance is already pushing it.
Tasha: 两天买票
Tasha: Two days to book a ticket.
Alice: 就是别人可能他一放票
Alice: Like others, they probably book as soon as the tickets are released.
Alice: 或者说是提前几天就是放票的
Alice: Or a few days in advance when tickets are released.
Alice: 提前几天
Alice: A few days in advance.
Alice: 可能就一共推往前推个一二十天
Alice: Maybe they push it forward ten to twenty days in total.
Alice: 就开始抢了
Alice: And then start grabbing tickets.
Alice: 然后我大学的时候也是
Alice: During my college days too.
Alice: 他们都已经开始想
Alice: They were already thinking about...
Alice: 哪天抢哪天的票了
Alice: Which day to grab tickets.
Alice: 然后每次都是快回家了
Alice: And every time it was almost time to go home.
Alice: 我想要不看看票吧
Alice: I want to check the tickets.
Alice: 一看啦啦啦售罄哈哈哈
Alice: Look! Sold out! Hahaha!
Jake: 哈哈是
Jake: Haha, yes.
Jake: 是有一次我回家飞南京然后
Jake: One time I was flying home to Nanjing and...
Jake: 就没赶上嘛
Jake: I missed the flight.
Jake: 自然而然没有赶上
Jake: Naturally, I missed it.
Jake: 呃那一天最后
Jake: That day, the last...
Tasha: 哈哈哈自然而然没赶上
Tasha: Hahaha, naturally missed it.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈自然而然没有
Alice: Hahaha, naturally missed it.
Jake: 对自然而然没有赶上
Jake: Yes, naturally missed it.
Jake: 所以所以那天看的最后一班
Jake: So that day, I caught the last one...
Jake: 回中国了
Jake: Back to China.
Jake: 先到了成都
Jake: First to Chengdu.
Jake: 对到了成都待了一晚上
Jake: Yes, I stayed in Chengdu for a night.
Jake: 我觉得成都到南京应该高铁也挺快
Jake: I thought the high-speed train from Chengdu to Nanjing would be quick.
Tasha: 然后也没赶上
Tasha: And you missed it too.
Katrina:  很很远很远
Katrina: Very, very far.
Katrina:  1,800公里
Katrina: 1,800 kilometers.
Jake: 对我我我以为挺快的
Jake: Yes, I thought it would be quick.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 还以为挺快
Tasha: Thought it would be quick.
Jake: 因为我想北京也挺
Jake: Because I thought Beijing is also...
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 就差不多距离吧
Jake: About the same distance, right?
Jake: 对吧大概有几个小时
Jake: Right? It should be a few hours.
Tasha: 啊然后赶上好吗
Tasha: So, did you make it?
Jake: 结果要那个是飞机场买的所以
Jake: But I bought the ticket at the airport, so...
Jake: 赶上哈哈哈哈
Jake: I made it, hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 就是去到成都之对那
Jake: So, I went to Chengdu and...
Jake: 那个是买到了成都之后
Jake: Bought the ticket after arriving in Chengdu.
Jake: 一晚上就在这个春熙路晃悠了一晚上
Jake: I wandered around Chunxi Road for a night.
Jake: 然后因为第二天早上的飞机
Jake: Because the next morning's flight...
Jake: 然后就飞走了
Jake: I flew out.
Jake: 原来想坐高铁的
Jake: Originally planned to take the high-speed train.
Jake: 结果
Jake: But...
Jake: 那个高铁大概也得七八个小时是吧
Jake: The high-speed train takes about seven or eight hours, right?
Katrina:  没有高铁
Katrina: No high-speed train.
Katrina:  成都到武汉都要9个小时
Katrina: Chengdu to Wuhan takes nine hours.
Katrina: 武汉到南京还要两三个小时
Katrina: It takes another two or three hours from Wuhan to Nanjing.
Alice: 线不一定
Alice: Not necessarily.
Katrina:  但是但是10小时以上
Katrina: But it's more than 10 hours.
Jake: 太可怕了
Jake: That's terrifying.
Katrina:  我一般都是买的飞机票
Katrina: I usually buy plane tickets.
Katrina:  我当时也以为
Katrina: I thought so too.
Katrina:  我以为那个武汉长沙
Katrina: I thought Wuhan and Changsha...
Katrina:  成都是挨在一起的
Katrina: ...and Chengdu were close to each other.
Katrina:  你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina:  武汉跟长沙只有一个小时
Katrina: Wuhan and Changsha are only an hour apart.
Katrina:  但是到到川渝那就很远
Katrina: But to Sichuan and Chongqing, it's really far.
Katrina:  就要6个小时
Katrina: It takes six hours.
Jake: 要绕一圈
Jake: You have to go around.
Jake: 我也觉得应该挺近
Jake: I also thought it was pretty close.
Jake: 我也觉得这个中国高铁应该没这么
Jake: I thought China's high-speed rail wasn't that...
Jake: 哈哈哈没这么慢
Jake: Haha, wasn't that slow.
Alice: ha ha ha ha
Alice: Ha ha ha ha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 我高铁有十几个小时
Jake: My high-speed rail takes more than ten hours.
Lucia: 到武汉
Lucia: To Wuhan.
Lucia:  比成都到北京还慢
Lucia: It's slower than from Chengdu to Beijing.
Lucia:  嗯总感觉好像
Lucia: Hmm, it always feels like...
Lucia: 感觉上应该就是他到北京更远一些
Lucia: It feels like it's farther to Beijing.
Alice: 现高铁是不是降过速了
Alice: Did they slow down the high-speed rail?
Alice: 现在高铁是不是降过速了
Alice: Did they slow down the high-speed rail now?
Alice: 现在一般都300多了
Alice: It's usually over 300 now.
Jake: 对都是300对
Jake: Yeah, it's all 300, yeah.
Alice: 嗯都是300多
Alice: Hmm, it's all over 300.
Jake: 300整怎么
Jake: Exactly 300, how...
Tasha: 太离谱了
Tasha: That's ridiculous.
Tasha: 他帮我找出来了北京到郑州的公交票
Tasha: He found me a bus ticket from Beijing to Zhengzhou.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Alice: 什么
Alice: What?
Jake: 倒多少趟
Jake: How many transfers?
Alice: 告诉我哈哈
Alice: Tell me, haha.
Tasha: 我说我说如果我不去
Tasha: I said, I said if I don't go...
Jake: 哎狭路共赏
Jake: Hey, narrow escape.
Tasha: 我说我说如果我24号去北京
Tasha: I said, I said if I go to Beijing on the 24th...
Tasha: 我他说不去打死我
Tasha: He said if I don't go, he'll kill me.
Tasha: 我说住哪
Tasha: I asked where to stay.
Tasha: 然后他说麻麻利利的把公交票订下来
Tasha: Then he said to quickly book the bus ticket.
Katrina:  让妈妈
Katrina: Ask mom.
Tasha: 哈哈啊
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你朋友是真人吗
Lucia: Hahaha, is your friend real?
Tasha: 你朋友是真人吧
Tasha: Your friend is real, right?
Jake: 北京任意点
Jake: Anywhere in Beijing.
Katrina:  不是怎么坐公交来这啊
Katrina: How are you going to take the bus here?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Tasha: 北京任意点到郑州
Tasha: From anywhere in Beijing to Zhengzhou.
Lucia: 是可以坐公交去郑州
Lucia: You can take a bus to Zhengzhou?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice: 我的天呐放门去
Alice: Oh my god, open the door.
Tasha: 上门接送
Tasha: Door-to-door service.
Lucia: 上门接送
Lucia: Door-to-door service.
Jake: 哈哈上
Jake: Haha, door-to-door.
Alice: 我的天呐哈哈哈
Alice: Oh my god, hahaha.
Jake: 专车是吧
Jake: A dedicated car, right?
Jake: 专车才280
Jake: A dedicated car is only 280.
Lucia: 对我也想问
Lucia: Yeah, I wanted to ask.
Lucia:  这么便宜啊
Lucia: That cheap?
Alice: 比我高铁还便宜
Alice: Cheaper than my high-speed train.
Alice: 但是时间太长了屁股要坐烂了
Alice: But it's too long, my butt would be sore.
Tasha: 10个小时
Tasha: 10 hours.
Tasha: 唉那好吧
Tasha: Sigh, alright.
Tasha: 9.5个小时
Tasha: 9.5 hours.
Lucia:  咱在国内也没必要
Lucia: We don't have to do that domestically.
Lucia: 做什么fuss或者哈哈哈
Lucia: Why make a fuss or hahaha.
Lucia: 会所BUS这种东西
Lucia: It's just a bus.
Tasha: 到那再说开宾馆
Tasha: We'll book a hotel when we get there.
Alice: 我看看
Alice: Let me check.
Alice: 不是他是怎么能想到这条路的
Alice: How did he even come up with this?
Alice: 我真是闻所未闻
Alice: I've never heard of it.
Tasha: 他一会让我骑自行车过去哈哈哈
Tasha: He even suggested I ride a bike there, hahaha.
Alice: 你骑个小黄
Alice: Ride a bike, really.
Jake: 北京到郑州自行车骑多久
Jake: How long would it take to ride a bike from Beijing to Zhengzhou?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: No idea.
Lucia:  到地了饭都
Lucia: The food's ready.
Jake: 就是五一
Jake: It's about May 1st.
Lucia: 接收站都不接收他
Lucia: The reception station won’t accept him.
Alice: 调度费太贵了哈哈
Alice: The dispatch fee is too expensive, haha.
Jake: 是
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 那我要用那种第一次的手机号去注册
Tasha: Then I have to use a new phone number to register.
Tasha: 然后他说新人首次可以免费调度
Tasha: And they said new users get free dispatch for the first time.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈你可以每路上每到一个城市
Lucia: Haha, you can change one or two Nicous in each city you arrive.
Lucia: 换一两个小黄
Lucia: Between adjacent cities.
Lucia: 就挨着的城市之间
Lucia: Just between the cities.
Tasha: 不是你在思考这件事的可行性吗
Tasha: Aren’t you considering the feasibility of this?
Tasha: 我到那要不要先治腿
Tasha: Should I treat my leg first when I get there?
Alice: 为了盘醋包了盘饺子
Alice: I made dumplings just for the vinegar.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice: 好像
Alice: It seems like...
Lucia: 为了保证你能顺利去郑州啊
Alice: 闻所未闻
Alice: Never heard of this.
Jake: 导航郑州哪个医院好
Jake: Navigate to the best hospital in Zhengzhou.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha
Jake: 骨科
Jake: Orthopedics
Tasha: 我懂了就这样子
Tasha: I get it, just like that.
Tasha: 我在中途然后摔倒了
Tasha: I fell in the middle of it.
Tasha: 然后郑州开救护车过来接我哈哈哈
Tasha: Then an ambulance from Zhengzhou came to pick me up, haha.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice: 郑州确实有
Alice: Zhengzhou really does have
Alice: 骨科医院
Alice: an orthopedic hospital.
Alice: 离东站不是很远
Alice: It's not far from the east station.
Alice: 可以到了直接去哈哈
Alice: You can just go straight there, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 也不用去宾馆了是吧哈哈哈
Lucia: So you don't need to go to the hotel, right? Haha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 五一
Jake: May Day
Jake: 五一放几天
Jake: How many days off for May Day?
Alice: 没看
Alice: Haven't checked.
Jake: 7天吧
Jake: Seven days, right?
Lucia: 少说5天嗯
Alice:休不够就请假
Alice: If you don't get enough rest, just take leave.
Lucia: 你你还可以大胆一点
Lucia: You can be a bit bolder.
Lucia: 休不够就翘课
Lucia: If you don't get enough rest, just skip class.
Tasha: 对啊我今天就翘课了
Tasha: Yeah, I skipped class today.
Jake: 什么课啊
Jake: What class?
Tasha: 什么课不重要
Tasha: The class doesn't matter.
Tasha: 我其实没见过他呢哈哈
Tasha: Actually, I've never met him, haha.
Jake: 好多人啊哈哈哈
Jake: So many people, haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Alice: 好多人啊
Alice: So many people.
Alice: 我看最近有什么演唱会的票
Alice: I'm checking for concert tickets lately.
Katrina:  这舞还行这版本
Katrina: This dance version is not bad.
Katrina:  1分5 6
Katrina: 1 point 5, 6.
Tasha: 在北京的医院居然要抢
Tasha: In Beijing, you actually have to fight for hospital appointments.
Tasha: 抢票你知道吗
Tasha: You know about fighting for tickets, right?
Tasha: 是要提前7天的时候就要开始抢
Tasha: You have to start fighting for them 7 days in advance.
Lucia: 哎我明明充电它为什么又变成低电量
Lucia: Hey, I clearly charged it, why is it low battery again?
Tasha: 那个医治的号
Tasha: The appointment number for treatment.
Jake: 那个我看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Tasha: 挂号费咋这么贵 100块钱
Tasha: Why is the registration fee so expensive? 100 yuan.
Alice: 你挂的是什么号啊
Alice: What kind of appointment did you get?
Katrina:  怎么又有SOLO啊
Katrina: Why is there another solo?
Tasha: 专家号
Tasha: Specialist appointment.
Alice: 专家号啊
Alice: Specialist appointment?
Alice: 那专家号是会贵一点
Alice: Specialist appointments are more expensive.
Jake: 呃没关系
Jake: Uh, it's okay.
Alice: 你会发现专家号也就给你诊疗个
Alice: You’ll find that specialists only give you a brief consultation.
Jake: 应该
Jake: Probably.
Lucia: 可是我刚办上的时候他还30%
Lucia: But when I first got it, it was still 30%.
Lucia: 但是中间有那么一小一小段时间没插
Lucia: But there was a short period when it wasn’t plugged in.
Alice: 点点时间
Alice: For a bit of time.
Tasha: 还有那种急诊预约挂号
Tasha: There's also emergency appointment registration.
Tasha: 500块钱一个号
Tasha: 500 yuan per appointment.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 我给你调个电多的
Jake: I'll get you a higher charged one.
Alice: 急诊
Alice: Emergency?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yes.
Alice: 急诊还得预约
Alice: You even need an appointment for emergencies?
Tasha: 啊都急诊了为什么还要预约
Tasha: Yeah, why do you need an appointment for emergencies?
Alice: 都急诊了为什么还要预约呢
Alice: Why do you need an appointment for emergencies?
Tasha: 就是紧急急诊预约号
Tasha: It's an emergency appointment.
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay.
Tasha: 500块一个人
Tasha: 500 yuan per person.
Jake: 嗯给你一个这个大的
Jake: Hmm, I'll give you the big one.
Jake: 就是大的
Jake: The big one.
Alice: 暂时还没有遇到过急诊的情况
Alice: I haven't had an emergency yet.
Jake: 贵的
Jake: The expensive one.
Tasha: 我们学校
Tasha: At our school,
Tasha: 校医院挂号都一块钱
Tasha: the clinic registration fee is just 1 yuan.
Tasha: 你们学校也是是吧
Tasha: It's the same at your school, right?
Alice: 因为有补助是吧嗯
Alice: Because of the subsidy, right?
Lucia: 我们学校医院刚开始就只要5毛钱
Lucia: At our school clinic, it used to be only 0.5 yuan.
Jake: 换一个
Jake: Change it.
Lucia: 后来加到两块钱
Lucia: 好过分啊
Lucia: That's so unfair.
Tasha: 那那是一块钱我
Tasha: That 1 yuan, I...
Jake: 对要保证上面的灯一直是亮着的
Jake: Yeah, you have to keep the light on.
Jake: 他才能充
Jake: Only then it can charge.
Tasha: 然后每次开的药都需要提个麻袋去
Tasha: And every time you get medicine, you need a big bag.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这有什么字啊哈哈
Lucia: Haha, what's with that, haha!
Tasha: 去提是吧
Tasha: To carry it, right?
Tasha: 哈哈是吧
Tasha: Haha, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 对是的他给你开药都是10盒起开
Tasha: Yeah, they prescribe at least 10 boxes.
Lucia: 没有这么夸张
Lucia: It's not that exaggerated.
Tasha: 这没有那么夸张吗
Tasha: Is it not that exaggerated?
Lucia: 我每次有了夸张的雄雌手
Lucia: Every time, it's like a ridiculous mix of male and female.
Tasha: 哈哈没有使用夸张学法
Tasha: Haha, not using exaggeration.
Tasha: 我比如说呃我最近有点感冒
Tasha: For example, if I have a cold,
Tasha: 他会给我开说哪里感冒
Tasha: they ask where it hurts.
Tasha: 你喉咙疼不疼
Tasha: Does your throat hurt?
Tasha: 我如果说喉咙疼
Tasha: If I say my throat hurts,
Tasha: 他会给我开喉咙疼的药
Tasha: they prescribe throat medicine.
Tasha: 喷喉咙的药
Tasha: Throat spray.
Tasha: 感冒灵颗粒解毒胶囊
Tasha: Cold granules, detox capsules.
Tasha: 哈哈开到一盒一种药就要开两三盒
Tasha: Haha, they prescribe 2 or 3 boxes of each medicine.
Tasha: 那种可能就就不要钱吧
Tasha: Maybe because it's free?
Tasha: 然后他就一直开
Tasha: So they keep prescribing.
Jake: 头疼医脑
Jake: Treating a headache with brain medicine.
Jake: 嗯哈哈
Jake: Hmm, haha.
Alice: 今年没有抢到一张票
Alice: I didn't get a ticket this year.
Jake: 什么票
Jake: What ticket?
Alice: 演唱会一张没抢到
Alice: Couldn't get a single concert ticket.
Jake: 都有啥呀
Jake: What all do you have?
Katrina:  我都找代抢了
Katrina: I even hired someone to get it for me.
Lucia:  让
Lucia: Let
Alice: 啊
Alice: Huh?
Lucia: 让杨老板
Lucia: Let Jake
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia:  用他的那些设备
Lucia: Use his equipment
Tasha: 设备帮你抢
Tasha: Equipment to help you get the tickets.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice: 啊可以吗
Alice: Oh, can he?
Tasha: 开启加速器
Tasha: Turn on the accelerator.
Jake: 开启7台电脑
Jake: Turn on 7 computers.
Katrina:  要搞一个Python脚本
Katrina: Need to write a Python script.
Lucia: 是因为他电脑多了
Lucia: It's because he has so many computers.
Jake: 哈哈哈一样的
Jake: Haha, it's all the same.
Jake: 那你猜这台电脑
Jake: Guess what, these computers
Jake: 就是这些电脑每一台都都是租的
Jake: All these computers are rented.
Jake: 然后租了十天
Jake: Rented for ten days.
Jake: 每一台多少钱
Jake: How much do you think each costs?
Jake: 你猜就是十天多少钱
Jake: Guess how much for ten days?
Jake: 一台
Jake: For one computer.
Tasha: 多少钱一台多少钱
Tasha: How much for one? How much?
Jake: 给个数给个数字吧
Jake: Give a number, just a number.
Lucia: 否则的话他就会买
Lucia: Otherwise, he'd just buy them.
Tasha: 100块钱
Tasha: 100 bucks?
Katrina:  我们学校竟然跳过这舞
Katrina: Our school even does this dance.
Jake: 差不多
Jake: Close enough.
Tasha: 我把我电脑借给你吧
Tasha: I'll lend you my computer.
Jake: 哈哈哈十天80啊
Jake: Haha, eighty for ten days.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Lucia: 十天80
Lucia: Eighty for ten days.
Jake: 十天80
Jake: Eighty for ten days.
Tasha: 80一天
Tasha: Eighty a day?
Jake: 十天一个电脑
Jake: Ten days for one computer.
Jake: 一台电脑八十
Jake: One computer, eighty.
Tasha: 10天
Tasha: Ten days?
Alice: 一天8块钱吗
Alice: Eight bucks a day?
Tasha: 一天才8块钱
Tasha: Only 8 yuan a day.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 多钱
Alice: How much?
Jake: 对一台电脑一天8块钱
Jake: Yeah, 8 yuan a day for one computer.
Jake: 可以不租了是吧
Jake: We can stop renting, right?
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 啊没有啊
Tasha: Ah, no.
Jake: 也可以租
Jake: You can also rent it.
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Really?
Katrina:  今天刷的这个5
Katrina: This one is 5.
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh.
Katrina:  是我们计算机艺术团的
Katrina: It's from our computer art group.
Katrina: 还有我们学校的
Katrina: And from our school.
Tasha: 80块钱10天
Tasha: 80 yuan for 10 days.
Katrina:  我学姐在杭州上班哈哈
Katrina: My senior is working in Hangzhou, haha.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 这正在上班
Jake: She is working now.
Tasha: 那我以后打游戏要不不买电脑了
Tasha: Then maybe I won't buy a computer for gaming in the future.
Jake: 就是这个是上班的时候跳的
Jake: She did this while working.
Tasha: 去租电脑吧
Tasha: I'll just rent a computer.
Katrina:  这是他那年的毕业晚会
Katrina: This was from her graduation party.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha: 但是我觉得他租电脑可能没有那么高
Tasha: But I think renting a computer might not be that expensive.
Katrina:  他大四我大一
Katrina: She was a senior, I was a freshman.
Jake: 哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh oh oh.
Katrina:  居然
Katrina: Unbelievable.
Tasha: 哦垃圾电脑
Tasha: Oh, a crappy computer.
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Katrina:  我4年前就跳过你
Katrina: I danced better than you 4 years ago.
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Katrina:  要跳舞吗哈哈
Katrina: Want to dance? Haha.
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: No idea.
Tasha: 弟弟得了一个怪病
Tasha: My brother got a strange illness.
Tasha: 要来北京治
Tasha: He needs to go to Beijing for treatment.
Tasha: 他在我们县医院治不好
Tasha: He couldn't be treated at our county hospital.
Tasha: 在扬州市医院治不好
Tasha: He couldn't be treated at Yangzhou hospital.
Tasha: 在南京市医院也治不好
Tasha: He couldn't be treated at Nanjing hospital either.
Katrina:  这太难了
Katrina: This is really tough.
Tasha: 然后要来北京医院寻医
Tasha: Then we need to go to Beijing Hospital for treatment.
Alice: 他怎么了
Alice: What’s wrong with him?
Tasha: 长不高
Tasha: He’s not growing.
Jake: 长不高
Jake: Not growing?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  多大了
Katrina: How old is he?
Tasha: 12岁
Tasha: He’s 12.
Alice: 缺什么维生素还是什么
Alice: Is he lacking some vitamins or something?
Tasha: only 1米
Tasha: Only 1 meter.
Alice: 1米大概
Alice: About 1 meter?
Jake: 1 米1米是多少
Jake: How much is 1 meter?
Katrina:  突变了吗
Katrina: Did he mutate?
Jake: 我有卷尺
Jake: I have a tape measure.
Jake: 好哈哈
Jake: Alright, haha.
Tasha: 啊不用
Tasha: Oh, no need.
Alice: 啊不用
Alice: Oh, no need.
Katrina:  啊不用
Katrina: Oh, no need.
Katrina:  那确实有点啊
Katrina: That’s indeed a bit...
Katrina:  12岁就这么点高
Katrina: 12 years old and only this tall.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Katrina:  当然好着急
Katrina: Of course, I'm so anxious.
Katrina:  男生女生啊
Katrina: Is it a boy or a girl?
Tasha: 男生
Tasha: A boy.
Alice: 他弟弟哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: It's his little brother, hahahahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: Haha, that's brilliant.
Katrina:  哦哦我没听见前面
Katrina: Oh, I didn't catch the beginning.
Tasha: 我觉得可能是生他生的比较晚
Tasha: I think maybe he was born quite late.
Katrina:  N激素啊
Katrina: N hormones, huh?
Katrina:  就是我有一个我爸爸同事就是他
Katrina: You know, my dad's colleague, he...
Katrina:  他自己那叔叔就很矮
Katrina: His uncle is really short.
Katrina:  就是
Katrina: So...
Katrina:  小时候就跟他儿子打那种什么硬骨
Katrina: When he was a kid, they gave him those bone growth injections.
Katrina:  骨骼发育的针
Katrina: Anyway, it cost thousands of bucks a year.
Katrina:  反正一年还要大几千块钱
Katrina: Because they were afraid he wouldn't grow tall.
Katrina:  因为怕他儿子长不高
Katrina: Since the uncle is only 1.6 meters tall.
Katrina:  因为那叔叔也就一米六
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 刚刚说要先来测骨相
Katrina:  对要测什么骨龄啊
Katrina: Yeah, to check the bone age, right?
Tasha: 看骨头还能不能再生长
Tasha: To see if the bones can still grow.
Katrina:  12岁应该还可以吧
Katrina: 12 years old should still be okay, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 是不是还会测什么骨缝
Alice: Don't they also check the bone seams?
Alice: 什么闭合酶之类的
Alice: And something like closure enzymes?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia:  对对要测
Lucia: Yes, yes, they need to check.
Katrina:  对对对要侧着
Katrina: Yes, yes, yes, they need to check that.
Lucia: 运动员也要测
Lucia: Athletes also need to check that.
Lucia: 那个
Lucia: That...
Lucia:  就是预测你接下来的身体发育情况
Lucia: It's to predict your future physical development.
Lucia: 小时候测过
Lucia: They measured it when I was a kid.
Jake: 想当运动员
Jake: Want to be an athlete?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 不是不是
Lucia: 我其实不想当运动员
Lucia: I actually don't want to be an athlete.
Lucia: 只是那会机缘巧合
Lucia: It just happened by chance.
Jake: 可以当运动员
Jake: You can be an athlete.
Jake: 但是不想当
Jake: But you don't want to be one.
Tasha: 还记得小时候我们学哦
Tasha: Do you remember when we were kids and we studied?
Tasha: 我上的班是什么国防班
Tasha: I was in some kind of national defense class.
Alice: 嗯当兵
Alice: Yeah, to be a soldier.
Tasha: 就是当兵当飞行员
Tasha: Yeah, to be a soldier, a pilot.
Lucia: 哇好厉害呀
Lucia: Wow, that's awesome.
Tasha: 当时还有一批当飞行员的那个筛选
Tasha: At that time, there was a batch of people getting selected to be pilots.
Alice: 你弟弟的高度有大概吧
Alice: Does your brother have the height roughly?
Tasha: 嗯当时还有一批当
Tasha: Yeah, at that time there was a batch of...
Tasha: 飞行员的筛选结果
Tasha: Pilot selection results.
Tasha: 前一天他体检前
Tasha: The day before his physical exam,
Tasha: 我不小心把他耳朵给划破了
Tasha: I accidentally cut his ear.
Lucia: 错了哈哈
Lucia: That's wrong, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哦
Jake: Haha, oh.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 飞不了了
Jake: Can't fly anymore.
Tasha: 我还在想完了他要是飞行员不通过
Tasha: I was thinking, if he doesn't pass as a pilot,
Tasha: 会不会就人家要来找我麻烦
Tasha: Would people come looking for trouble with me?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈就是飞行员
Lucia: Haha, pilots.
Tasha: 就是飞行员身上不是不能有伤口吗
Tasha: Pilots can't have any wounds on their bodies, right?
Alice: 嗯对
Alice: Yeah, that's right.
Tasha: 啊结果他成绩没有考过
Tasha: Ah, in the end, he didn't pass the test.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 虚惊一场
Jake: False alarm.
Lucia: 虚惊一场
Lucia: False alarm.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这不是我的问题首先
Lucia: Haha, it wasn't my fault in the first place.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 这不是我的问题首先
Tasha: It wasn't my fault in the first place.
Jake: 对对对撇清关系撇清责任
Jake: Yeah, yeah, clear yourself of any responsibility.
Alice: 今天还得看视力
Alice: Today they also have to test vision.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice: 就我们那个女女的宇航员刘洋嘛
Alice: You know, our female astronaut, Liu Yang.
Katrina:  嘘这太
Katrina: Shh, this is too...
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina:  这个核心力量太吓人了
Katrina: Her core strength is so scary.
Alice: 他当时就是
Alice: At that time...
Katrina:  什么时候能跳成这样啊
Katrina: When will I be able to jump like that?
Jake: 可以就这个吧
Jake: Maybe this one?
Jake: 哈哈哈对
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Katrina:  这个是我开始玩的
Katrina: This is how I started playing.
Jake: 确实很高哈
Jake: It's really high.
Katrina:  我OK我关注up主
Katrina: Okay, I'll follow the uploader.
Lucia: 他好厉害
Lucia: He's amazing.
Katrina:  我去这就力量型爵士
Katrina: Wow, this is power jazz.
Alice: 就他曾经上的那个学校
Alice: So, the school he used to go to...
Katrina:  就这样一下我脖子咔嚓一声哈哈
Katrina: If I do that, my neck will crack, haha.
Alice: 那个那个那个那个那个宇航员
Alice: That astronaut...
Katrina:  嗯喜欢看一些大佬跳舞
Katrina: I like watching those pros dance.
Alice: 他原来就是
Alice: He originally...
Alice: 上学的时候就是参加选拔吗
Alice: When he was in school, he participated in the selection, right?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice: 就好多人被筛掉就是因为视力不过关
Alice: Many people were screened out because their vision wasn't good enough.
Alice: 但是他当时视力就
Alice: But his vision at that time...
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina:  太厉害了
Katrina: So impressive.
Tasha: 但是当飞行员视力都要很好
Tasha: But to be a pilot, you need excellent vision.
Katrina:  娜娜记录
Katrina: Nana, record this.
Tasha: 然后身上没有伤口
Tasha: And no wounds on your body.
Alice: 嗯是的对
Alice: Hmm, yes, that's right.
Tasha: 然后好像还要转圈保持平衡
Tasha: And it seems like you also need to spin around to keep your balance.
Katrina:  我我看一下
Katrina: Let me check.
Katrina:  你要跳舞吗或者是
Katrina: Do you need to dance or what?
Tasha: 我也没有通过
Tasha: I didn't pass either.
Jake: 宇航宇航员
Jake: Astronaut, astronaut.
Jake: 宇航员
Jake: Astronaut.
Katrina:  跟那个偶像万万岁
Katrina: With that idol, long live idols.
Tasha: 对哦不好意思是飞行员我
Tasha: Oh, sorry, it's actually a pilot.
Jake: 对宇航员
Jake: Yes, astronaut.
Alice: 宇航员
Alice: Astronaut.
Katrina:  还有good time
Katrina: And "Good Time."
Jake: 飞行员就要这样
Jake: Pilots need to be like this.
Katrina:  呃就是这个
Katrina: Uh, just this one.
Katrina:  还不如good time对吧
Katrina: Not as good as "Good Time," right?
Katrina:  然后猪猪侠我们排掉了
Katrina: And we eliminated Piggy Hero.
Tasha: 要不跳
Tasha: Or not dance?
Katrina:  排除的排吗
Katrina: Eliminate it?
Katrina:  排除了OK OK
Katrina: Eliminated, okay, okay.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Jake: 哈哈哈哎呀我去
Jake: Hahaha, oh my gosh.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我就会一个动作
Tasha: Hahaha, I only know one move.
Katrina:  哎我可以跳yes OK可以
Katrina: Oh, I can dance, yes, okay, I can.
Lucia: 哎呦我刚也看了一个东西
Lucia: Oh, I just saw something too.
Alice: 中有你是吗
Alice: Is it you?
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈是吧
Tasha: Hahahaha, right?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Katrina:  可以跳yes OK其实也
Katrina: I can dance, yes, okay, actually...
Jake: 对很重要
Jake: Yes, very important.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: 呵这是精华是吧
Jake: This is the essence, right?
Alice: 杨超越那个是啥呀
Alice: What was Yang Chao Yue's?
Katrina:  差不多跟我高中跳那个
Katrina: Almost like the dance I did in high school.
Tasha: 呃我不知道哎
Tasha: Uh, I don't know.
Tasha: 创造101吗
Tasha: "Produce 101"?
Alice: 青春有你是谁啊
Alice: Who's in "Youth With You"?
Katrina:  我那两个分不清哼
Katrina: I can't tell those two apart.
Katrina:  那两个节目
Katrina: Those two shows.
Alice: 有没有男团
Alice: Are there any boy bands?
Alice: 男团是啥
Alice: What's a boy band?
Katrina:  男团是那就是范丞丞他们出道
Katrina: A boy band is where Fan Chengcheng debuted.
Lucia: 范丞丞他们出道
Lucia: Fan Chengcheng's debut.
Katrina:  那个是什么来着
Katrina: What's that show called again?
Tasha: 什么也是什么
Tasha: What show are you talking about?
Alice: 哎呦我的天
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 创造101吗
Tasha: Is it "Produce 101"?
Tasha: 我不清楚了
Tasha: I'm not sure.
Alice: 时代少年团是谁啊
Alice: Who are the "Times Youth League"?
Tasha: 少年台
Tasha: Youth League.
Alice: 哎
Alice: Eh.
Katrina:  少年团是直接公司出道的
Katrina: The Youth League debuted directly from the company.
Katrina:  没有选秀那个
Katrina: There was no talent show involved.
Katrina:  TF的那个家族
Katrina: They belong to the TF family.
Tasha: 你要收回来吗
Tasha: Are you going to take it back?
Jake: 没有我就玩
Jake: No, I'm just playing.
Alice: 我刚一折
Alice: I just folded it.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 好你最多能跳出来多少米
Tasha: Okay, how far can you jump?
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my.
Tasha: 我居然也想到了这个无聊的游戏
Tasha: I can't believe I thought of this boring game too.
Jake: 他可能这个是这个
Jake: Maybe this is just how it is.
Jake: 这东西的上限跟人关系不大
Jake: The limit of this thing doesn't have much to do with people.
Jake: 我感觉
Jake: I think.
Tasha: 我我其实刚刚想的就是挑战一下
Tasha: Actually, I was just thinking about challenging it.
Tasha: 最高能折多少米
Tasha: To see how far we can fold it.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 好我们来猜一下最高还能折多少米
Tasha: Okay, let's guess how far we can fold it.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 谁能猜对
Tasha: Who can guess right?
Jake: 呵呵呵把这全吃了
Jake: Haha, whoever guesses wrong has to eat all of this.
Tasha: 谁要是猜错了就把这些全吃了好吧
Tasha: Whoever guesses wrong has to eat all of this, okay?
Jake: 那都全吃了
Jake: Then everyone will have to eat it all.
Tasha: 让我看一下现在多少米了
Tasha: Let me see how far it is now.
Jake: 那你看啥呀
Jake: What are you looking at?
Jake: 你要猜
Jake: You have to guess.
Jake: 现在一米4243
Jake: Now it's 1.4243 meters.
Tasha: 好你猜多少
Tasha: Okay, what do you guess?
Jake: 我猜一米45
Jake: I guess 1.45 meters.
Tasha: 就是就就会蛰掉
Tasha: It will just sting.
Tasha: 我们以那个为失败
Tasha: We consider that a failure.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 让我赌一米6
Tasha: Let me bet 1.6 meters.
Alice: 我觉得你要完了哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: I think you're done for, hahaha.
Tasha: 啊啊那我要赌一米五
Tasha: Ah, then I'll bet 1.5 meters.
Jake: 我也觉得你要完了啊
Jake: I also think you're done for.
Jake: 那也差不多完了
Jake: That's pretty much it.
Tasha: 你是一米多少
Tasha: What's your guess?
Alice: 哈哈哈 1米45
Alice: Hahaha, 1.45 meters.
Jake: 一米一米四五
Jake: 1.45 meters.
Tasha: 那我就读一米六
Tasha: Then I'll bet 1.6 meters.
Jake: 那你想吃你就
Jake: Then if you want to eat, just...
Jake: 吃吧你要不
Jake: Eat, if you want to.
Tasha: 那我赌一米555吧
Tasha: Then I'll bet 1.555 meters.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 你要多少
Jake: How much do you want?
Tasha: 1米55
Tasha: 1.55 meters.
Jake: 一米55
Jake: 1.55 meters.
Alice: 1米55跟一米45差10公哈哈
Alice: 1.55 meters and 1.45 meters differ by 10 cm, haha.
Jake: 你你自己来你自己来一米55
Jake: You, you do it yourself. You do 1.55 meters.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha.
Alice: 因为它越长它这个
Alice: Because the longer it gets, it...
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哇哦
Jake: Wow.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice: 你悄悄作一下臂
Alice: Just quietly move your arm.
Alice: 你可以把你的手往前伸一点
Alice: You can extend your hand a bit further.
Alice: 但也伸不了多远
Alice: But you can't stretch it too far.
Tasha: 哎好了啊可恶仔
Tasha: Okay, alright, fine.
Alice: 好了这才一米三多哈哈哈
Alice: Okay, it's just over 1.3 meters, haha.
Jake: 挺强的
Jake: Pretty strong.
Katrina:  这副歌跳了3遍
Katrina: We danced this chorus three times.
Katrina:  其实他新动作不是很多哎
Katrina: Actually, he didn't have many new moves.
Jake: 挺强挺强
Jake: Pretty strong, pretty strong.
Alice: 没事
Alice: It's okay.
Alice: 这玩意会割伤手
Alice: This thing can cut your hand.
Jake: 嗯小心点
Jake: Yeah, be careful.
Katrina:  其实难度不大
Katrina: Actually, it's not that hard.
Katrina:  我看了一下全是那个
Katrina: I looked at it, it's all like that.
Alice: 慢慢的
Alice: Take it slow.
Katrina:  然后奔跑青春你还要再看一下吗
Katrina: So, do you want to watch "Youth Running" again?
Alice: 杠杆的感觉
Alice: The feeling of leverage.
Katrina:  奔跑青春跳出来蛮好看的
Katrina: "Youth Running" looks quite good.
Alice: 没关系没关系
Alice: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina:  但是感觉只能跳一分钟
Katrina: But I feel like we can only dance it for a minute.
Alice: 哎呀拉地了哈哈
Alice: Oh no, it's dragging, haha.
Tasha: 啊哈哈别
Tasha: Ah, haha, no.
Jake: 哈哈哈来吃开吃
Jake: Hahaha, come on, let's eat.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake: 这是用什么
Jake: What's this made of?
Jake: 这是加了什么别的材料吗
Jake: Did you add any other ingredients?
Jake: 除了面面粉面粉面粉鸡蛋没了
Jake: Besides flour, flour, flour, and eggs, nothing else?
Alice: 面粉
Alice: Flour.
Tasha: 面粉鸡蛋
Tasha: Flour and eggs.
Jake: 嗯可以
Jake: Hmm, it's good.
Jake: 这什么曲子
Jake: What's this song?
Jake: 我去小孩吗
Jake: Oh my, is it for kids?
Jake: 这都
Jake: This is...
Katrina:  高中生
Katrina: High school students.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 我真没见过蘸白糖的吃法
Alice: I've never seen it eaten with white sugar.
Jake: 真的吗对那确实可能只有那一片
Jake: Really? Yeah, it might only be in that area.
Alice: 嗯对
Alice: Hmm, yeah.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice: 那有甜豆腐脑跟咸豆腐脑
Alice: There are sweet and salty versions of tofu pudding.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 那我们吃吃咸豆腐呢
Tasha: Then should we try the salty tofu pudding?
Jake: 啊已经不记得了
Jake: Ah, I don't remember anymore.
Jake: 现在好像这什么店都能开
Jake: Nowadays, it seems like any kind of shop can open.
Jake: 已经不知道以前是什么味儿
Jake: I don't even know what it used to taste like.
Jake: 因为有很多外地的人吧
Jake: Because there are a lot of people from other places.
Jake: 所以什么味儿都有
Jake: So, there are all kinds of flavors.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  这一分半
Katrina: This one and a half minutes...
Katrina:  感觉跟那个跟3分的差不多
Katrina: Feels almost like the three-minute one.
Katrina:  看下也是OK
Katrina: It's okay, too.
Jake: 这后面什么字
Jake: What's written here at the back?
Jake: 这是一个团
Jake: This is a group.
Jake: 哦好吧
Jake: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 狗剩子不知道
Tasha: Gou Sheng doesn't know.
Alice: 谁是狗剩子
Alice: Who is Gou Sheng?
Jake: 我们后面也放一圈
Jake: We'll put a circle at the back too.
Jake: 呵呵放一个什么呢
Jake: Haha, what to put?
Lucia: 因为是自己设计一个logo哈哈
Lucia: Because it's a self-designed logo, haha.
Jake: 哈哈可以
Jake: Haha, that's fine.
Lucia: 因为每个练舞人就是就是那样
Lucia: Because every dancer, you know...
Tasha: 哈哈是吧
Tasha: Haha, right?
Lucia: 就会在后面放
Lucia: They will put it at the back.
Tasha: 不记得了
Tasha: Can't remember.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 坐你旁边吧
Alice: Sit next to you?
Lucia: 然后每次上完课之后
Lucia: And every time after class...
Lucia: 就会有人拿那个酷炫的那个有有
Lucia: Someone would bring a cool, you know...
Lucia: 说什么云台的相机
Lucia: Like a gimbal camera.
Katrina:  可以跳yes okay了
Katrina: Can do a "yes okay" dance.
Lucia: 然后给你录往前往后
Lucia: And record you going back and forth.
Katrina:  哈哈其实可以跳yes okay
Katrina: Haha, we can actually do a "yes okay" dance.
Jake: 哦OK OK
Jake: Oh, OK, OK.
Lucia: 然后录出那种视频的效果
Lucia: And record that kind of video effect.
Tasha: 或者那个什么呃
Tasha: Or that...uh...
Katrina:  我要不发群里
Katrina: How about I post it in the group?
Katrina:  你们自己挑
Katrina: You guys choose.
Katrina:  说服一下那个修硕
Katrina: Convince Shure.
Tasha: 啊太阳你干啥
Tasha: Oh, Sun, what are you doing?
Katrina:  哈哈拉进来呗
Katrina: Haha, pull him in.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Katrina:  我最喜欢看男生跳女团舞了
Katrina: I love watching guys dance girl group dances.
Jake: 他可以跳
Jake: He can dance.
Jake: 我觉得可以
Jake: I think he can.
Katrina:  还可以我觉得
Katrina: I think he can too.
Alice: 我觉得跳起来没准比我们还
Alice: I think if they jump, they might be even
Katrina:  对比我们更妖娆的有可能
Katrina: More graceful than us, it's possible
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Ah
Alice: 还还娇羞呢
Alice: Even more shy
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Alice: 哈哈娇俏哈哈哈
Alice: Haha, charming, hahaha
Katrina:  这也不是很快吗
Katrina: Isn't this quite fast too?
Tasha: afterlike afterlike
Tasha: afterlike, afterlike
Katrina:  Afterlife那是不是有点难
Katrina: Afterlife, isn't that a bit hard?
Tasha: 有点难吗
Tasha: A bit hard?
Katrina:  嗯那是女团舞
Katrina: Yeah, it's a girl group dance
Alice: 好多男生在广场跳那个黄舞
Alice: Many guys dance that yellow dance in the square
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Tasha: 还有那个Dota
Tasha: And also that Dota
Katrina:  低头吗还是什么
Katrina: Bowing or something?
Tasha: 到对头
Tasha: Yeah, bowing
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina:  低头那有点难那个
Katrina: Bowing, that's a bit hard
Tasha: 那个有点难吗
Tasha: Is that a bit hard?
Tasha: 他那个节奏很简单吧
Tasha: The rhythm is simple, right?
Katrina:  他那个跳不出那个牛津斯的感觉
Katrina: He can't dance like Newton
Katrina:  这还行是吧
Katrina: This is okay, right?
Katrina:  这多少 1分 43 还行
Katrina: How much, 1 minute 43 seconds, it's okay
Tasha: afterlike
Tasha: Afterlike
Katrina:  afterlike我看看啊
Katrina: Afterlike, let me see
Alice: 是不该换水了
Alice: Should we change the water?
Katrina:  呜呜呜哎
Katrina: Woo woo, hey
Katrina:  昨天昨天新换的
Katrina: Yesterday, we changed it yesterday
Katrina:  嗯afterlike好有意思
Katrina: Hmm, afterlike is so interesting
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Katrina:  张元英的团
Katrina: Jang Won-young's group
Tasha:  是的
Tasha: Yes
Katrina:  这有点难
Katrina: This is a bit hard
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Tasha: 挑战张元英转圈舞那个
Tasha: Challenge Jang Won-young's spinning dance
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha
Jake: 哈哈哈可以
Jake: Hahaha, sure
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Katrina:  是真爱豆啊
Katrina: She's a true idol
Katrina:  看张元英的
Katrina: Look at Jang Won-young's.
Lucia: 两天都经常跳
Lucia: She dances often every two days.
Lucia: 很有力量才
Lucia: She's very powerful.
Lucia: 能跳出它这个效果来
Lucia: That's how she achieves this effect.
Lucia: 我觉得我们这几天可能好不了
Lucia: I think we might not be able to do it in a few days.
Katrina:  呜啊啊
Katrina: Ugh...
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 得从健身开始
Jake: We need to start with fitness.
Alice: 要跳给谁看
Alice: Who are you dancing for?
Jake: 呃呃呃
Jake: Uh, uh, uh...
Lucia: 嗯呃我们
Lucia: Uh, us.
Katrina:  那也是OK吧
Katrina: That's okay, right?
Jake: 相机哎
Jake: The camera, hey.
Lucia: 可我们还不是有什么九刀救无穷
Lucia: But we still have the Nine Blades to save the infinite.
Katrina:  虫子
Katrina: Bugs.
Jake: 呵呵呵对
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Lucia: 哈哈哈啊
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 九到正无穷
Jake: Nine to infinity.
Tasha: 啊这么可怕
Tasha: Oh, that's so scary.
Lucia: 这么可怕
Lucia: So scary.
Jake: 14亿全国人民
Jake: 1.4 billion people in the country.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵不
Jake: Haha, no.
Alice: 能不能是全球人民
Alice: Could it be the whole world?
Jake: 七十亿全球人民
Jake: 7 billion people worldwide.
Katrina:  人民
Katrina: People.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 七十亿全球人民呵
Jake: 7 billion people worldwide, haha.
Katrina:  帮我拿下手机
Katrina: Help me get my phone.
Alice: 这个吗
Alice: This one?
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Tasha: 按那个台舞吧
Tasha: Press that dance platform.
Tasha: yes you see you say
Tasha: Yes, you see, you say.
Jake: 像这个领域大概有有100个组
Jake: In this field, there are about 100 groups.
Jake: 100个组在做
Jake: 100 groups doing it.
Jake: 如果他们都用你们的这个数据的话
Jake: If they all use your data.
Jake: 就至少是100个研究员
Jake: That's at least 100 researchers.
Jake: 他们要看你们跳舞
Jake: They need to watch you dance.
Jake: 对呵呵呵呵呵对
Jake: Yes, hahaha, yes.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 处理一下
Lucia: Handle it
Jake: 对对对但是是但是你们就会跳舞吗
Jake: Yeah, yeah, but can you dance?
Jake: 对没事
Jake: Yes, it's fine
Lucia: 没事他不知道是我就行
Lucia: It's fine, as long as he doesn't know it's me
Jake: 是是没问题
Jake: Right, right, no problem
Lucia: 不知道是我就是
Lucia: As long as he doesn't know it's me
Lucia: 其实我拍的也无所谓
Lucia: Actually, it doesn't matter if I film it
Lucia: 就算就算自打也不知道是咋回事
Lucia: Even if, even if it's self-shot, he won't know what's going on
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: It's over
Katrina:  lady Candle呀
Katrina: Lady Candle
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Alice: 简直不敢相信我要是跳这个舞
Alice: I can't believe it, if I dance this
Alice: 会有多扭曲
Alice: It would be so awkward
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 疯了吧
Tasha: Are you crazy?
Katrina: 那舞你看着简单好像没什么用力
Katrina: That dance looks simple, like it doesn't take much effort
Katrina: 但是你跳上很丑
Katrina: But when you dance it, it looks ugly
Katrina: 你跳不出张元英那种感觉
Katrina: You can't bring out the Zhang Yuanying vibe
Katrina: 好就他们团的舞
Katrina: Well, their group's dance
Katrina: 我就我经常不知道怎么发力
Katrina: I often don't know how to put in the effort
Tasha: 那yes OK
Tasha: Then yes, OK
Tasha: 确实很简单啊
Tasha: It is indeed very simple
Alice: 来我家玩吧
Alice: Come play at my place
Tasha: 看能不能抢到医院的票
Tasha: Let's see if we can get tickets to the hospital
Tasha: 我可能五一就要跟我妈妈在北京看病了
Tasha: I might have to go to Beijing with my mom for her treatment during May Day
Tasha: life
Tasha: Life
Alice: 拜服
Alice: Impressive
Katrina:  发大群里吧万一他们还有
Katrina: Post it in the big group, maybe they still have some
Lucia: 剧组会不会跟我们一起跳
Lucia: Will the crew dance with us?
Jake: 可以跳可以跳
Jake: They can dance, they can dance
Alice: 剧组是不是就最后一天会来
Alice: The crew will only come on the last day, right?
Jake: 呃也不是周五吧
Jake: Uh, no, Friday, I think
Jake: 周五他们上课啊
Jake: They have classes on Friday
Alice: 今天周几
Alice: What day is it today?
Jake: 今天就会来两个
Jake: Today, two of them will come
Jake: 上课打卡
Jake: Class check-in
Jake: 呃就是紫藤唯一的女生她要打卡
Jake: Uh, the only girl from the crew, she has to check in
Jake: 他们实验室要打卡
Jake: Their lab has a punch-in system.
Jake: 所以不太方便来
Jake: So it's not very convenient for them to come.
Jake: 周末可以来
Jake: They can come on weekends.
Jake: 周五周六周日
Jake: Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
Katrina:  奔跑的青春要分享吗
Katrina: Do we need to share "Running Youth"?
Lucia: 要不分享一下让大家看一看
Lucia: How about sharing it so everyone can see?
Lucia: 然后觉得不过不好
Lucia: And if they think it's not good,
Lucia: 像现在这几个里面
Lucia: Like among these now,
Lucia: 应该属于比较难的一个
Lucia: This one should be one of the harder ones.
Katrina: 还有个简单一点的
Katrina: There's also an easier one.
Jake: 放到管家群
Jake: Post it in the butler group.
Jake: 管家一起跳就给你们开小车的
Jake: If the butlers dance together, you'll get a small car.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: That's possible too.
Lucia: 欢迎
Lucia: You're welcome.
Jake: 你们都做过了吗
Jake: Have you all done it already?
Jake: 都做过了
Jake: All done.
Alice: 我没
Alice: I haven't.
Jake: 你还没有做哦
Jake: You haven't done it yet?
Jake: 今天给你
Jake: You'll do it today.
Jake: 今天还有一次
Jake: There's still one more today.
Alice: 但我没快递
Alice: But I don't have a courier.
Jake: 没关系今天该兜风了嘛
Jake: No worries, today we're going for a ride anyway.
Katrina:  该买嗯
Katrina: Time to buy, hmm.
Lucia: 我们如果要买东西的话
Lucia: If we need to buy something,
Jake: 对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Katrina:  OK这4个挑吧
Katrina: OK, pick from these four.
Lucia: P人的快乐时刻就是让他用帮忙决定的
Lucia: The joy of P-people is letting him help decide.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Katrina:  投票吧
Katrina: Let's vote.
Lucia: 而且因为我这几年就是我我
Lucia: And because in recent years, I, I...
Lucia: 我前两年就开始
Lucia: I started a couple of years ago...
Jake: 哦对就是这个
Jake: Oh right, that's the one.
Lucia: 这个是我们
Lucia: This is ours.
Jake: 这个没有办法一起挑
Jake: This one can't be chosen together.
Katrina:  什么风格
Katrina: What style?
Jake: 对嗯
Jake: Yes, right.
Katrina:  给我看看
Katrina: Let me see.
Lucia: 这个是前前年的一个
Lucia: This is from two years ago.
Katrina:  啊我就说你有脂肪
Katrina: Ah, I knew you had some fat.
Katrina:  感觉你很有这个气质
Katrina: You have a great vibe.
Lucia: 然后我之前学了一段时间跳
Lucia: And then I learned dancing for a while before.
Lucia: 但这几年都没怎么跳了
Lucia: But I haven't danced much in recent years.
Katrina: 嗯我一般跳爵士
Katrina: Hmm, I usually dance jazz.
Katrina:  有点偏民族现代
Katrina: It's a bit more like modern ethnic.
Lucia: 对对可能更现代舞一点
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, maybe more modern dance.
Lucia: 因为我是没做过民族这个课
Lucia: Because I never took ethnic dance classes.
Lucia: 我们当时是教现代舞
Lucia: We were taught modern dance at that time.
Lucia: 然后所以就我直接躺下去
Lucia: So I just lay down directly.
Lucia: 就是老师说你们要用到快点学了之后
Lucia: The teacher told us to learn quickly, so I lay down.
Lucia: 然后我就躺下
Lucia: Then I just lay down.
Katrina:  你这好有气质
Katrina: You have such a good vibe.
Katrina:  这个这个
Katrina: This, this.
Katrina:  我有点跳不来
Katrina: I can't really do it.
Katrina:  因为我感觉我没那么柔
Katrina: Because I don't feel that flexible.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This.
Lucia: 而且这个也不适合咱们这个场地
Lucia: And this isn't suitable for our venue.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  我们学校办金秋舞蹈时候
Katrina: When our school holds the Golden Autumn Dance Festival,
Katrina:  就全部都跳这种舞
Katrina: everyone dances this kind of dance.
Alice: 可以坐我旁边吗
Alice: Can I sit next to you?
Katrina:  跳那种讲历史的那种舞
Katrina: Dancing those historical-themed dances.
Alice: 喜欢跟你在一块
Alice: I like being with you.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈可以可以
Jake: Hahaha, sure, sure.
Lucia: 这个我忘编的
Lucia: I forgot to choreograph this.
Lucia: 我们老师让每个每个同学定
Lucia: Our teacher asked each student to decide.
Katrina:  你哦你自己编的
Katrina: Oh, you choreographed it yourself?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 我们老师让每个同学自己选一个音乐
Lucia: Our teacher asked each student to choose a piece of music.
Lucia: 然后编一段
Lucia: And then choreograph a segment.
Lucia: 然后但其实我只编了前一分半
Lucia: But I actually only choreographed the first minute and a half.
Lucia: 随后一份半我就胡乱无吐哈哈
Lucia: The following minute and a half I just improvised, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  心理素质好强啊
Katrina: Strong mentality!
Katrina:  居然能当人的面糊了
Katrina: You actually improvised in front of people.
Lucia: 哈就有点有点推荐卡拉OK那个意思
Lucia: Haha, it's a bit like recommending karaoke.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 后面我就开始随意发挥
Lucia: After that, I just started to freestyle.
Lucia: 把前面的东西再抄一遍
Lucia: And copied the stuff from the beginning again.
Jake: 可以freestyle
Jake: You can freestyle.
Lucia: 不然没有人知道他原本是什么样的
Lucia: Otherwise, no one would know what it originally looked like.
Katrina:  看一下如果这个只有1分多
Katrina: Look, if this is only a little over a minute...
Alice: 这个舞来跳
Alice: To dance this routine...
Alice: 不知道有多丑陋哈哈哈
Alice: I don't know how ugly it would look, hahaha.
Lucia: 因为疫情的时候就是回国
Lucia: Because during the pandemic, I went back to China.
Lucia: 然后不是有一段时间就刚好
Lucia: And there was a period of time when...
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 马上就是就要结束了
Lucia: It was about to end.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 但是就是还没有
Lucia: But it hadn't yet.
Lucia: 那个当时
Lucia: At that time...
Lucia: 还没有就是
Lucia: It hadn't...